do it round
was the hardest emotional experience
that I've had in my life ever American
Idol contestant nutsa tells her side of
the story after she was accused of
sleeping through rehearsals it's just so
wild on last week's episode nutsa and
Karina teamed up for a duet but when
nutsa went to bed early Karina was upset
it hurts my feelings when somebody
doesn't take
nutsa eventually came back down to
practice with Karina but let's just say
things were tense we have to stick
together and make this together work
yeah because it's 3am it's hard for
everyone everyone is nervous but you
have to do it again and try it again and
make it perfect so let's do it right
it's gonna bring emotions out and that
could come in the form of Tears anger
surprise
I have to feel confident with the
outfits I feel confident by over
practicing and when it came time to
perform Karina let the judges know what
was up we had a couple of issues last
night what were the issues some people
wanted to sleep instead of working wait
she went to sleep while you were
rehearsing
yes the two went on to perform their
rendition of Nina Simone's I Put a Spell
on you and Katie called the whole thing
underwhelming we give them constructive
criticism and they're really entering
into a a university a crash course a
fast pace
crash course of the music industry Katie
Lionel Richie and Luke Bryan sent Karina
home but pushed nutsa onto the next
round where she slayed a solo
performance of Tina Turner's Proud Mary
forever
[Music]
and that's how we got news's thoughts on
the Karina drama it was really hurtful
for me it really hurted me I never do
bad to people I was trying my best to
stay positive try it again until it's
perfect if you answer negativity with
negativity it's gonna have worse results
and Nitza don't forget about Grace more
grace
when newta had her moment with the
judges she explained why she didn't say
anything on stage after the duet I
wanted to apologize because I felt very
bad when you said to me like more grace
more grace and I wanted to like tell
also my side of the story I then I
didn't wanted to bring negative energy
so that's why I didn't say nothing
because I didn't want to cry on stage
but after I left the stage like I was
just destroyed and Katie said she can
relate to all that I know what it means
to be a strong woman want to be strong
and to never break and never to feel
exactly you know like anything could get
to me but that's not that's not real
yeah I think that they're seeing that
you're a real person with a big heart
yes a big heart thank you and a big
talent I mean the humility and Grace and
character that these contestants have I
mean they're all just great human beings
but I know what you're wondering ring
did she make it through to the next
round for us it was clear you're going
to the top 24. all the tears I had to
the last round now I'm happy
[Music]
foreign